watching thanks back 2002 is the first
ratchet clank bunch watching clanks
camed since then one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven eleven
or twelve i think is including like the
HD remaster and ones that know it
includes one of the collections yeah
okay then all for one that that four
player thing baby want the question
booty tools of destruction in frontal
assault yep up your arsenal that one's
very good you so many but they've taken
away the the quippy subtitles and just
gone for straight-up ratchet clank so
this is like a reimagining of the
original game it's like a it's almost
like they pulled all the resources and
developments over the years and yes
remade essentially more or less the same
game as far as like plot and like
different planets I know but pulled in a
lot of different weapons throughout the
years of the series right which is like
perhaps the most entertaining thing
about watching club yeah one of them all
the crazy ones that they've they've put
in there i'm assuming there is a groove
it Ron in this game yeah right I was
using it last night I'm right at the end
of the game and I was using it against
like the bosses and it because in the I
assumed it wouldn't work on the giant
bosses but it still does and I know
that's right their own dances really
it's really dumb but it's awesome it's
like my experience having actually not
played any of the games in series
getting thrown into this game was live
12 already went up like my highlights of
the year hmm uh the game just blew me
away the bursting you know it's
something different it's not division
you know it's like depressing nature
this is like a colorful vibrant game
with just so much charisma fun just fun
and I it's addicting I beat it twice a
game twice it's weird I had a similar
thing with the PlayStation 3 games where
I have not really pledged like I always
on PlayStation but for some reason just
never got into ratchet clank and then I
played some of the ones on ps3 and
right let's talk about one of the I
guess main talking points of these games
whenever they come out ratchet clank has
always been like a really great looking
series like for whatever reason and
sound like I've just been able to like
make really fantastic looking games and
this one from the trailers looks pretty
gorgeous to you guys think gorgeous yeah
absolutely like everything about that
game just like stands out I think I like
what having looked at the original hmm
they've changed up the planets a little
bit like same planet named same same
level design for instance one of the
planets is like a and this game is like
a very much a snow planet in the
previous it's just more of a dark
looming one running me one which was
kind of what like they press today they
basically rearrange the planets in a
very awesome way we're like when you get
to the snow planet just before you've
played a very orange gassy lava planet
right i mean so as the game goes on like
you you kind of get eventually kind of
worn out on this one planet and then to
flip it to the snow one was like yes
like really different vite like strike
contrasting pallet sky yeah join each
one yeah and each planet is everything
like that so you just kind of go through
and it's just a really fun ride out of
does it there's a play like a bunch of
the old watching client games i mean
we're seeing a lot of returning weapons
you know it's a 3d action platformer at
the end of the day does it feel very
familiar does a lot of new stuff in it i
see the rail sliding is back in it they
took the best part of all the like as
the games progressed and just implanted
it on the first game it's very much like
resin evil remake it's still the same
game but it's it's very much updated but
there's new things added in to keep the
the people who were on board right from
the beginning interested but also bring
in new players like Rob right but it's
very much yeah like the first game
didn't have a aiming reticle it was just
very pure third person so the gun would
shoot whatever direction ratchet was
facing and not necessarily where the
camera was facing yeah so then they
introduced me that was pushing yeah it
was probably because playstation one
games it wasn't that much screen right
to play with and then in going commando
they they threw that in and then up your
arsenal that was like the default but so
having that now and being able to you
know like still swing the wrench in any
direction but pulling like having to the
reticle itself just feels so good it
makes it feel you know what we're used
to now it's like to analog shooters and
everything it feels like they took
everything they learn
from the series and just put it back on
the original game which is a really good
feeling to like see these planets again
as someone who played that I think I
played retching Clank on release day
ever I 2002 and it feels really good to
kind of keep the Rose tinted glasses on
right really nice feeling yeah this is
like a you imagine yeah well we get so
many remakes or like uh pres games now
and it's not like movies where you wait
like 30 years before you do it games
were pretty young so you could do it
after 14 years or anything but just at
the uncharted collection for God's sake
sure and it's as someone who's been with
the series a really long time it's
really refreshing to see a new palette
but also just remember how bad it might
have felt but it feels great right now
and some criticisms in the twitch chat
about the fact that they've locked at
the 30 frames a second as well and i
think it was digital found you were
speculating that that would be to give
it a more cinematic feel so to feel a
bit more like the movie the dot bother
you guys at all having this like lucious
world but it having a relatively dry
what's funny when we streamed the demo
which we got a while ago someone asked
that same question is this 60 frames and
i said yeah i think it is bright quit so
you couldn't tell and there's absolutely
no framedrops that's for sure you know i
mean like it's a very fluid polished
looking game I guess you anime stew like
you can animate to a frame rate that's
that's gonna sound like the most
everything in a row but like no you can
animate you know to sort of plug those
gaps right and it's a very well animated
series so presumably this game and it's
in it'll it almost glorifies the
animations of these characters like
you're you're basically able to get away
with the cartoony nature of motion blur
which is like a very prominent thing in
animation and cartoons I feel like an
intern adjust it gives it gives the game
more like a like a breathing cartoon
which like I absolutely love and this is
a really good link that just got posted
in the chat actually and which I think
has been modded so I'll pop up like in
myself actually from black noise which
is insomniac actually posting about if
framerate matters back in 2009 and
there's a bunch of like interesting sort
of statistics oedipus saying that it
does not significantly affect sales of
the games or reviews of the games or
anything like that I mean that must be
something they knock your heads off
against a lot at the start we were
talking about how these games have
always been really
good looking like that's something we've
we've known about them for a long time
or something we've we've associated with
these games for a long time so
presumably that's actually a big part of
it she's not worrying necessarily about
the frame rate yeah it's such a weird
case actually playing this remake it's
one of the few games where the the way
it looks when you're playing it actually
to me looks better than the cutscenes
because the cutscenes are the one place
I don't like this game it's actually
really weird remembering which cut
scenes were in the original game and
seeing them now they didn't really do a
ton to them to actually like in
animation wise uh the original
conversation when you meet the plumber
or you meet big al it's still weird
because um ratchet won't really move
that much he'll just kind of move his
eyes up and down like a mass effect one
character but the new cutscenes look
great there's the part where this
warship explodes the smoke looks like
almost out of place in this game it
looks really good right but when you're
actually playing it and rashes jumping
around and you're avoiding people in
pulling out the pie rossiter just burn
people it looks I would say like the
gameplay itself looks better than the
cutscenes almost maybe not a traditional
sense but I enjoyed it more well they're
all there are also kind of two levels of
cutscenes right you got your actual
clips from the movie right and then you
got your more like an engine basically
well like more because there's a lot
more that happens we'd seen the movie we
can talk about it but there's a lot more
that happens in the game hmm and so
you're getting like you know like
planets that that are in this game trend
like talk about are you now let's talk
about the movie at all I really really
want to talk about the movie doesn't
count the 29th so we're not supposed to
talk about the movie until it 28 okay
sorry vice yeah yeah and right but these
cutscenes are awesome the ones that are
from the movie they're super funny and
these ones are really well done and then
what I'm trying to get out as are these
other cutscenes which are like you know
you meet these side characters that
again the other nature of like the
gameplay feels more alive than these
like very like I don't I don't say other
than like there's not much animation
going on it's just like you know a
couple of like generic like shrugs I
think that's what you were getting at
like so can you tell when the ones are
from the movie yeah I was just gonna get
to wait like it so if you want if you
haven't seen the movie could you tell
which ones were in the movie like
knowing there's a movie that they're
billing the game is a game based on a
movie which is based on the 2002 the
game which is if it's confusing it
should be let's do it
it's Street Fighter the the movie today
yeah yes when you're playing the game
especially like I can talk about this
because you there are cutscenes that
just serve the purpose of setting up the
next gameplay sequence or just they feel
very much like their book ending these
planets we get an info bot that leads
you to a new planet right like this
makes sense in the game but then you'll
see this cutscene that doesn't really it
it's supposed to add color to the
characters and make the story better
it's supposed to but you're like this is
clearly made for the movie that's okay
cutscene this is a scene that is
supposed to be in this overarching
narrative and they feel a little out of
place so I know you can't talk about the
movie so I'm going to ask you so what I
what I kind of want to know is how many
of these movie cutscenes are in the game
like I'd say less than half the
cutscenes you see in the game from the
movie so however I'm original time back
like a total time total time totally
game that looks like I license from a
movie that looks like it might be from
the movie I'd say about like half an
hour like half an hour of them we're
more a little more rightly more I'd say
okay I can't wait to have you guys on to
talk about the movie because yeah
presumably you've seen for simply
anyways played the game has seen a third
of the movie yeah I wonder a little more
than alerted yeah the problem that's
being yeah that's weird yeah okay did
you guys play the game or watch the
movie first the movie I played I played
I played the demo we played the demo
before the movie right oh god no we had
seen but I played the original game
before I saw the movie right yeah yeah I
saw her game is so good I love the game
like really good it's this awesome game
um just I have to say like uh actually
I'm going with this other than I'd like
I just want people to play this game I I
think it's like a must-have for ps4
right I really do um I think the humor
is like pretty great it's very
self-aware you know you get this
cowboy's musharraf yeah Oh like the
captain Qwark character oh yeah like
makes you laugh my self aggrandizing
yeah and like he's basically hyping up
your tedious gameplay of like I smashed
boxes for by the way that you know all
the rack stand and coins you amount is
like crack
you just go I go out of every wife
corner looking for every little like
nuke and cranny to get that stuff and
you know right off the bat you do that
and he like has some line at I like like
his his love for destruction of property
was through the roof and like hey he's
talking about that's how they
contextualized the game now it's as if
quark is in prison after the events the
later games and he's recounting the
story but narrating it so instead of
giving you this tutorial on screen or
the tutorial voice it's him he'll be
like ratchet use the triangle button to
pull up his weapon to get through the
enemies using his destination destiny
yeah that's right that's really funny
just those jokes in the game are really
funny yeah I laugh a lot yeah to go to
the old unreliable narrator as well
that's good all right so I guess
watching blank out today on PlayStation
4's right I play and we'll have you back
on to talk about the movie and not too
distant future I guess a couple of weeks
a month yeah wonderful alright a mom
coming into the mother month okay in two
months okay but if you want to see some
of the movie now play ratchet and clank
sounds like all right let's say also
sorry there is a review up on gamespot
com so I Cassidy moves you did at eight
out of ten you can go check that out
right now as well and a video
you